my introduction to cryptocurrencies so
now that I've explained or given you a
high-level overview of the workings of
Bitcoin what I would like to do in the
second hour is explain how several
aspects can be improved and what other
later cryptocurrencies have done so I'll
look at anonymity scalability and
expressiveness anonymity is actually
they're all very relevant to this
workshop because they use zero knowledge
proof in particular to achieve anonymity
but also new proposals to get
scalability so let's start with
anonymity so I think we're all agree
bitcoin is not anonymous because if you
have a currency where everything is
public even if your name is not there
then you can analyze which payments are
spent how and you can do analysis of of
the transaction graph do that what can
you what kind of anonymity can you
achieve within Bitcoin so the first
thing that was proposed is that if you
want to somehow have coins that are not
associated to you why don't you send
them to some centralized so called
mixing service and then they mix the
coins and then they give you back
another random coin often they don't
give you back any coins so that was not
a good idea there's thus better ways to
do this and one of them is called
Cointreau and I'll show you quickly and
then I'll talk about approaches done by
other cryptocurrencies in particular the
Monaro and G cash are the main anonymous
cryptocurrencies
today
so what is Cohen joined kwangin is
basically the simple idea that if you
have a transaction which has inputs and
outputs then this is atomic in the sense
that there's no link between which input
goes to which output so if Alice and Bob
want to mix their coins what they could
do is that they put in the same amount
of Bitcoin so Alice puts one here into
here Bob puts three here and they create
two new outputs two new coins with new
public keys and then no one can
associate who owns which coin and the
nice thing about this is that because
they need to provide provide their
signatures on this transaction no one
can cheat the other because you would
only sign a transaction which gives you
back your money
other types of anonymity that were
proposed as well by by Greg Maxwell is
confidential transactions where the idea
is that you want to have a payment
system where you hide the amounts that
are transacted so this is not compatible
with Bitcoin but this is for example now
implemented amonia the big problem here
is that if you hide the amount that go
in and let go out then by say encrypting
them how can the minor check that you
have not just invented new money in your
transaction so you need means to prevent
that you want that the sum of the input
values equals the sum of the output
values and that's actually something
that Dan Boneh already talked about you
can use this you can achieve this by
using homomorphic commitments why
because if your inputs and outputs are
committed and if they're so now you
don't sum the actual values but the
commitments themselves and if that
evaluates to the same then by the
binding property the security property
of the commitment you can deduce that
the same amount of value went in
so if I have time I'll actually show you
some details of that now let's see what
else money are owed us
besides hiding the amounts so it's based
on a proposal called crypto note that
propose two ways of making payments more
anonymous were one concerns hiding the
spender of over transaction and one is
about hiding the receiver so hiding the
spender is done by a cryptographic
primitive and to give this talk with one
of the inventors of it in the room
called ring signatures and hiding
receiver is done by a concept called
stealth addresses which I'll quickly
explain so who knows what ring
signatures are
okay so the difference between a
standard signature you have a
verification key and a verification key
in the signing key and in a ring
signature what you can do is you can
collect a ring or a set of verification
keys you make a signature that verifies
with respect to this set of keys and the
guarantee is that one of the owners of
one of the keys has actually made the
signature so one of the the secret keys
that are associated to these
verification keys was used to make the
signature
so the initial motivation for this was
whistleblowing so if you if you work for
a government agency you want to disclose
some information you don't want people
to know who you are but you also want to
convince a the journalist that you are
actually an employee there what you
could do is you collect a lot of keys of
of employees you make a ring signature
so people can get be convinced that one
of the employees
so you can basically hide among a set of
other people and that's exactly the idea
of how you can hide the sender of a
transaction so in Bitcoin remember we
had a transaction had an input and the
input referred to one of the outputs of
a previous transaction in the blockchain
now if you instead of using regular
signatures use ring signatures what you
do is say you're the owner of this
unspent transaction output and you want
to spend it then you just select random
other UTX O's and then you make a ring
signature Sigma which now guarantees
that one of the unspent transactions in
this blockchain has been spent so it
seems it gives you kind of an anonymity
because you don't know which one was
spent but it seems to completely break
the whole idea of double spending
because first of all what is what is
even an unspent transaction output if
someone put this inside a ring but
didn't really spend it it should remain
unspent so that's not clear so there's
no more real concept of unspent
transaction output there's only outputs
that might have been referenced or not
but whether they were spent or not you
don't know also this basically enables a
very simple double spending attack say
you've used your secret key here you put
it in a ring you've spent this money
created this transaction and then later
you make another transaction and you use
the same key again how can people check
if you don't know which one was spent
you don't know which one must double
spend so this is soft by not using pure
ring signatures but a primitive called
traceable ring signatures which allows
you to link so if you have a ring
signature it's completely anonymous of
which of the keys was used to sign but
if you have two signatures that use the
same key then you can link them so now
people can if they see a new signature
they can check whether it links to one
of the old ones and if so
it means that the key had already been
used and so they rejected as being a
talisman
so that's that's implemented in Manero
it turns out that it's quite important
of how you pick these other outputs
among which you want to hide the
primitive yes because the first analysis
showed that using some heuristics
correct me if I'm wrong you can actually
trace people because like a simple
heuristic was if you just put any
transaction outputs in the blockchain
and most likely you are the actual one
will be the ones that occurred latest
also if you have a lot of you basically
can can infer things right if you know
that this one it was that one who spent
they can't have been another one so you
can eliminate and you can like do an
analysis yes not as far forward SD cash
how much you're still thinking
sometimes I think that needs a CNN drug
they're receptive to analysis a couple
dates should they know I think deployed
in their water to some measures on being
more careful about how you do to the
other
yes so they changed the coin age here at
stake to adapt to their research so we
don't look to a patent mouse button it
might converge to something certainly
much more acceptable and enough
anonymity
okay so what so this allows you to hide
when you're the spender actually hiding
as a receiver it's a lot easier because
if in Bitcoin every time someone wants
to send you money you create a new
address and send them their address in
private then no one can trace you
because all you see is random addresses
on the blockchain however if you do that
then you cannot have for example be an
NGO and publish a Bitcoin address for
donations you would have to interact
every time you want to receive money so
that would like you can't have
non-interactive payments where you have
someone's account number and just send
money to it so that would be a
disadvantage and stealth addresses
actually allow you to have both at the
same time so you can publish an address
and people can use it to send you money
without talking to you but still the
payments they make to that address look
completely unrelated to your address and
that I think is a cute trick that I'll
show us some one of the more technical
things in this talk so the idea is that
[Music]
the idea is that so I have let's say
this is my address I know the key for
this address I publish it and if people
want to send me money what they do is
they create they derive a related
address from my address which looks
unrelated and transition key that allows
me if I get this key to derive from my
original key and this transition key
this new key for that address okay
that's that's the idea so if someone
sends me money sends it to an address
which looks completely unrelated to mine
and he gives me some information that
allows me and only me to derive the key
to this new address and then you send
the money to this new address and I know
the secret keys away
so this can be done using this group so
I guess to be precise so we've seen this
before so you lose you use a group over
an elliptic curve it has a generator so
some element G and you can define X
times G as adding G to itself you want
the discrete logarithm problem to be
hard so if I give you some element H you
cannot find the x such that x dingy x
times 2 itself gives you this element H
and this is what's already used in
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
namely for ECDSA the elliptic curve
designing algorithm which is used in
Bitcoin or for North signatures which is
more popular now among newer
cryptocurrencies secret key is the
scalar X and your public key is secretly
PD x generated by something simple like
the decision
privately
you could do that to the public key and
encrypts the secretly and secretly with
my public key and yeah yeah yeah because
because then you would have a payment on
the blockchain which belongs to you
because you have the secret key but it
still belongs to the same as well
because he knows the secret key as well
so you don't want to be only one of many
owners of the payment that's why so in
Bitcoin an address is actually the hash
off but ignore that a public key for
ECDSA and the value X is a secret key so
in a stealth address you actually have
to group elements let's call them
capital A and capital B and you see in a
minute why there must be two it's
actually exactly the reason I just said
so what does the receiver do he chooses
a random scalar why he creates this
transition key defined as Y times G so
it looks like a Bitcoin public key for
this secret key and the stealth address
order sorry the the one-time address
that is created will be the hash of
small Y times capital a so the the
randomness he picked and this part of
the receivers public key times the
generator plus the other part of the
public key okay so for the
cryptographers you see well this is
actually the diffie-hellman shared key
between a and y which means that it's a
value that you can obtain either by
knowing small Y or by knowing small a so
the sender has created it by knowing
small Y but it's actually equivalent to
a small a times capital Y which means
that the owner of this address who knows
small a
can also create a compute this value and
if you look at this equation you see
that the secret key for this new address
is actually a value that can be computed
from the secret key of the old address
plus this Capital y that must be sent to
the receiver what's the point of B so
what if B was not there then the secret
key for this new address would be small
a times Capital y which is this value
which the sender knows so you would send
it to an address where which would
basically amount to the same as what you
proposed to have an address to which the
the sender still knows the secret key
yeah I guess you could
okay so as yeah as I said this small
this is the the secret key belonging to
the new address and it's something that
you can obtain from these two values
so that's Manero it uses some cool
crypto to hide different aspects of
identities or amounts using different
methods and then the in contrast G cash
goes a very different route it uses one
big hammer to hide everything and that
became as non-interactive to your
knowledge proofs in as instantiated by
zk snarks so it's based on the zero cash
protocol buy pencils on keys green
carmen maura stroma and visa correct
it's a fully anonymous currency again
I'll ignore some details and it uses
these CK snacks and it's actually
deployed as Z cash when it's one of the
thirty so what's the idea the idea is so
it basically goes back to my very first
thing I showed you namely serial numbers
now a coin is a commitment to a serial
number again I'm skipping the actual
details and the idea is that you have on
your blockchain you have all the coins
which basically correspond to what would
be transaction outputs in Bitcoin and
you commit to all this coin using a
Merkle tree so that's some concise
representation of all of them which
allows you to actually prove to someone
that something is there and when you
spend one of the coins you create a new
coin it's like creating a new Bitcoin
address which again is a commitment to
zero number plus some secret information
that only the owner knows and what you
do is you prove that you actually knew
the secret that you've spent a coin that
existed in in the
old state of the system and that the
value do transferred didn't create any
new money that you were the owner and so
on and you prove this by using a sneaky
snark exactly so for now this again it's
like the straw man it doesn't work
because exactly for the same reason as
in money arrow you cannot just use ring
signatures because you need some
mechanism to prevent people from
spending the coin twice if all you prove
is I know some coin that belongs to me
and now I that's that gives me the right
to create this new coin okay but who can
check that you haven't done this twice
for the same coin so what how zero cash
solves this problem is similar actually
to destroy scible ring signatures
every time you spend the coin reveal its
serial number and the snack proof takes
care of the fact that you've actually
given the right your number so you're
the state of the system is all the coins
that ever existed whether they're spent
or not plus all the serial numbers of
all the coins that have already been
spent so it's somehow dual to Bitcoin
where the state of the system is
represented by all the unspent
transaction outputs so you need to
remember what's what is the money that's
still in the system whereas here you
need to remember what's the money that's
not in the system anymore
okay that's so you can do this
efficiently using zero noise snarks and
you get a completely anonymous
cryptocurrency there's small drawbacks
to this the first one is that I mean
this has improved by using newer snack
systems that it's slow I think in the
beginning you had to like to compute the
transaction that contained the snack you
had to compute for several minutes now
it's like less than a minute seconds
okay good so that has improved a lot
pardon and I guess the biggest drawback
viewed from the Monaro community is that
it has these trusty parameters so has
anyone in the in the first two days
really we didn't really get that far to
see structured seriesis did we do we see
structured CRS is in the first two days
something that must be there but I
didn't distinguish
yeah so the problem is that this trusted
reference string with respect to which
these are not these non interactive
proofs are made has a certain form and
it has a form that you can only compute
if you know some secret value which
unfortunately if you know that secret
value also allows you to prove false
statements that's why the zero cash
people refer to it as the toxic waste
which is some value that you need to
convince your users no one knows because
only if no one knows this value okay a
simulation trapped err for the
cryptographers then you know that your
system is sound I mean it's like it's
it's the same as why do you verify
signatures in Bitcoin because you want
to be sure that the the view of the
blockchain you have is correct and
consistent and here instead of
signatures we have snacks so it's
basically replaces what our signatures
in Bitcoin so the if you start mining Z
cash then you would download the whole
history you would verify all these
snacks and if you remember the the first
two days while these snacks are really
or can be hard would have been hard to
compute the very very fast to to verify
that's why this actually scales and and
you can verify all the transactions that
have to say jump on the street who has a
crypto volume what's the difference
what duffer's has to do in Z capture
this one arrow or I think it's I think
it's similar to Bitcoin whether I mean
if you're a full node you have to you
you have you can check everything but
that's that's resource intensive if you
if you have other light clients for Z
cash for so for non zero the
transactions I guess the user is
creating the snacks
yes exactly so I think you can view
really the snack is whatever the
signature does for Bitcoin is what the
snark does for the cash
is that just like a design layer on top
was that necessary so you're not
referring to serial numbers versus coins
all right just to know in in actual
that's why I said I'm not going through
all the details in actual Z cache
there's two types of transactions you
have these anonymous transactions but
you also have regular transactions which
don't give you privacy but they live in
the same block
any more questions
okay so the the problem is that you have
this toxic waste so if you just have the
the Z cache people say here's the
parameters how do you know that they
didn't keep the secret and then just
create new money if they want some more
money what they did is they ran a big
ceremony among very different types of
actors and jointly computed these these
public parameters using multi-party
computation so that if there was at
least someone honest among all these
people you can be sure that no one knows
this toxic waste what about so this
gives you soundness of protection
against someone counterfeiting coins
interestingly anonymous anonymity holds
even if everyone in the ceremony was
corrupt
thanks to this properties of snacks
equals subversion zero knowledge were
even if as long as you check some
consistency of the parameters
even if someone malicious created the
CRS anonymity would still hold
okay that's so much for anonymity so the
second property I wanted to talk about
the scalability so the Bitcoin
blockchain is basically continuously
increasing and it's now over 230
gigabytes so people asked whether
there's a way of avoiding of having
better scalability so in terms of how
much information has to be stored but
also in terms of how you can increase
throughput so one of the one of the
proposals a few years ago again by an
anonymous author I guess to add some
mystical aura to it was called min blue
in BO and it it promises to there would
Bitcoin does but in a more scalable way
in the sense that in Bitcoin your block
chain stores the whole history of what
ever happened what happened since the
beginning since the Genesis block and
mim-mim bow-window tries to do is only
store in the blockchain the information
that is relevant now that is what are
the coins that exist in systems and
cryptographic information that ensure
that this is this is a coherent state of
the system
so remember this is the picture forming
boom bow sorry for Bitcoin we have
blocks this is the blockchain vertically
we have transactions if I spend the this
output here in this new transaction I
give a signature that authenticates it
with respect to this public key now the
signatures ensure that if this is my
transaction and only I know the secret
key thanks to unfortunately no one can
spend it and it also since all the
amounts are public it also ensures that
no one can just create the transaction
that creates money by itself because
minus would not accept that so remember
this is basically if you download the
whole blockchain you go through
everything you verify everything that
all you care about in the end is what
are the transactions that have not been
spent yet because if you late to see a
new transaction you just have to verify
with respect to that set whether it
spends one of these unspent transaction
so drawbacks all the transactions are
public so we have weak anonymity and all
data must be kept forever to have this
public verify ability of the system
which leads to bad scalability what
would be good scalability so look at
consider this chain of transactions
where this transaction spends this
output here which spends this output and
so on then basically all you would care
about is not which path this transaction
output took to get here because this
rejection will spend anyway so why can't
we just erase it from the blockchain why
can't we just say well whatever was here
is now there and forget about what
happened in between that would be kind
of a memory less blockchain can you do
this in Bitcoin
not if you want to have verifiability
because this signature verifies with
respect to this public key and so on so
if you really if you want to check that
this transaction is legitimate you have
to check all the previous transactions
so this idea of cut through that you can
just erase transactions that have
happened in the mean time but that are
not that have been spent already does
not work in Bitcoin and that's what what
me moving Bo promises to do so since I
have yeah I'll go over it quickly so
this will be I guess the most technical
part I'll tell you when if you get lost
on the way so the starting point for me
marimba was confidential transaction so
remember confidential transaction was
can I hide the amount of input and
outputs of of a transaction the way this
is done this is what Dan mentioned in
his talk using the type of commitments
that you use to hide the values is
called pettersen commitment and you have
two generators age and G of of your
elliptic curve group and a commitment is
you put your value here multiply it by H
plus some random value times G and since
this value is completely random
this C is a random group element and
this completely hides your value on the
other hand if discrete logarithm is hard
in this group you cannot find a
different representation of a Quincy so
this this gives you what's what's called
binding so if you have a commitment is
really only one value that you you can
take out of it
so remember the problem with hiding the
amounts is that you have to have some
mechanism that ensures that whatever
comes out of a transaction would save us
the money that you can spend afterwards
shouldn't be greater than what you put
in and the idea is that as I mentioned
on the slide before that what is
homomorphic encryption is allow you to
do is instead of taking the value of
summing the inputs and the outputs and
checking whether they are the same you
just do the same thing
with the commitment and because they're
homomorphic this works and because
they're binding this is secure so if you
look at the sum of the output
commitments minus the sum of the input
commitment you can rearrange terms so
basically you get that this is a
commitment to the difference of the sum
of the values with the randomness being
the difference of the sums of the
randomness so if you choose the
randomness correctly then this will this
sum here will be the zero element of
your group this is what confidential
transactions does
any questions yep something stupid
because I don't understand but we
started from some Genesis block and we
have to believe like that we're looking
at your Genesis block why not just do
the same thing and saying well we
believe in the block like block a
million it's a year old we just believe
in that block right all the account
balances at that point that's happened
up the chain for me yeah I mean there
are there are these ideas of putting
checkpoints into into the the blockchain
but the thing is who is in charge of
putting the split checkpoints it's part
of basically as part of the system is
like hard-coded in your system of course
you could download like a faulty Bitcoin
client but that's kind of the how you
bootstrap trust in the beginning whereas
the the checkpoint is something where
you're not sure if someone could have
like worked around it or something but
at least the Genesis block is yeah
something I mean you need some basic
anchor of trust in the beginning
whatever that process should also be
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess I
mean this you can only reduce trust up
to some point where you have to start
and then your question is to start from
Genesis block where do you start
for like from some initial reference
client that's produced or what is why
should I trust the person what if
somebody comes with a longer
it's spring cleaning
well but I mean you're saying all put
the whole you ticks and say into a club
I mean in secretary gigabytes perfect
for I mean no it's more but it's still
less than the entire chain nobody not to
believe music so you trust them to first
the tennis pro so you're not saving
anything yeah thank you but I think this
doesn't give you trust either because if
you just see like sorry not that it
doesn't give your trust but because
there's a limited amount of trust that
didn't see - because suppose you look at
the light coin
suppose your client was configured to
look at light coin instead of Bitcoin
everything's you check out if this
doesn't tell you whether you looking at
vidcon of litecoin you still need some
kind of reference initial reference if
the initial reference could have been
the Genesis block why can't it be this
checkpoint for me and go
I'll just so this is for who's really
interested so you can do this balance
checking by looking at commitments and
then you get a problem because you could
create a transaction that's valid
because it spends two one and one
bitcoins and it creates minus five and
nine bitcoins so the sums check out so
that's again referring back to dance
talk that's what you use range proofs
for so with every commitment you need to
prove that this value is actually
contained in some interval of reasonable
amounts so you've white Lisa
so here's what we moving build us and if
you look at it first then I guess you
don't believe that this can be secure if
you if you use confidential transactions
on top of a Bitcoin like system then in
order to spend the coin you need to know
the secret key that goes with the public
key so you can make the signature and
you need to know the opening so the
randomness here of this commitment so
you can then create a balanced
transaction okay so there's two
informations now where one is for
authenticity and one is basically for
for privacy so what member Weber
proposes is well if this coin has some
secret value anyway can we just say this
is the secret key for the coin and
forget about signatures altogether
so this doesn't seem very secure but it
turns out it is but the first problem we
need to solve is that if this is the
secret key of the coin again we have to
make sure that the sender doesn't know
the secret key of the coins that are
created but if we still use this
equation to check a well balanced Ness
and say there's only one input and one
output then the randomness has to be the
same so necessarily the sender knows the
secret key so this is solved in a
slightly different way which lets every
coin have its independent randomness
which means that this sum here will not
cancel out typically so instead of
getting the 0 element of the group we
get 0 times H if the transaction is
balanced plus some X times G and so
instead of checking whether this is zero
we give we interpret this as a public
key or in other words we prove that we
know an opening of this to 0 or in other
words we prove that we know the secret
value X here and it turns out that at
the same time this proof also guarantees
authenticity of of this transaction so
it guarantees that if you own that coin
no one else can spend it so basically
this one signature takes care of all the
security properties that we want in some
very magical way yes
signature so like here you can just
assume the the empty message for its own
public key exactly because exactly
because it's I mean in the employ
instantiation you could sign like the
the block I things like that but the
reason is that you actually the property
you need from it is not that it's a
signature but that it's a proof of
knowledge of an open but since it's more
signatures that I use to instantiate it
people talk about it okay so basically
what is the nice consequence of this is
that if we have two transactions
so recall inputs are now you can really
think of them as being the coins our
commitments you have this value x1 which
is the difference of the sums and the
signature that says that yes these this
transaction is well balanced and if you
have two of them then not very
excitingly you can put them together
basically you can sum these two
equations so you get the sum of the of
the joint outputs minus the sum of the
joint inputs equals the sum of these
single differences okay that's basically
a non interactive version of join coin
join because it can be done a posteriori
and not while the users that create the
transaction are are present so we get a
new transaction which has again a
similar condition for being valid but
now the magical part that happens and it
allows you to do this cut through is the
following if you started with the
transaction
where which has some output that was
then spent in the second transaction
meaning that these two commitments here
are the same group element the end what
you can do is you can just erase it
and still your transaction will remain
valid why because this equation would
still hold because you removed it here
and here okay so you can take a
transaction and if this transaction
comes from transactions where one spent
outputs of another transaction then you
can actually forget about them and your
contraction still remains valid
yes but then what you can so the thing
is that yes you have your blockchain but
then you can basically create a
condensed view of the blockchain where
you do all these cut throughs and that's
your state of the system and that's all
you have to verify even if there is some
history that was of course in the
blockchain before because if something
is already only spent later on and it
will be here but you have this
verifiable global view of the system yes
exactly you could you could even exactly
that will give you even better anonymity
because they won't even appear in the
project so we have actually managed to
get something that so you can you can
yes you just add a merkel hash of it
into every block and then whoever wants
to join someone has to give him the
actual full thing and you can check it's
the right commitment ok so this means
that basically a since every input to
transaction is an output of a previous
transaction if you just do it to all the
transactions in the system everything
will cancel out and how long can you do
this well until you hit a coinbase
transaction so a transaction where money
was created so basically if you keep
your blockchain basically is now the
merge of all transactions and everything
that was spent cancels out so everything
that's left is on the left-hand side the
only inputs that were not canceled out
we're the ones that are coinbase
transactions of where the money was
created and on the right
inside everything that's not cancel out
is everything that hasn't been spent yet
so this is your ugh sauce and then you
have these values that allow you to
verify that everything has happened
correctly
so what have I saved here I still have
to store that all if I want to verify
that this is the state I have to store
it I have to check all the history you
you can check no you could you could
just check the headers of the blocks
okay an interest of time I'll rush
Russia on so this this was yes how the
privacy compares worse because if you
have so I mean it's it's I think people
talk about it as solving a privacy issue
but I view it more as solving the
scalability issue so it happened it it
it hides the amounts that's true but you
I mean if you know who some coin belongs
to and then you late to see it being I
mean you see which coin spent when right
whereas in the cash you just know that
some point that it that existed was been
so privacy wise I guess it's like we
prove secure that there is some some
limited form of privacy that you can
prove which is basically about the the
amounts that are transferred but the
main thing we prove secure is that no
one can create transactions that creates
money and no one can steal anyone else's
coins which i think is the because like
when you look at it and you say oh let's
get rid of the signatures that's really
when you start out together other thing
is secure and and it turns out
so other since one of the topics of the
of the program is zero knowledge proof
and snarks other approaches is there's a
proposal called coda I think which
basically uses snarks not for the zero
knowledge property which is why z cash
uses them but for their succinctness so
the idea is let's let's just show this
by pictures so suppose we have this this
was at the very beginning this ledger
where you have the account balances and
this one is a legitimate update of this
if Alice confirmed that yes she was ok
with Bob now owning her Bitcoin right so
here the idea is that how can you make
everything concise you again you use
Merkel trees
so you commit to this list of accounts
so you have the root of your Merkel tree
which is just one hash function output
and now you give a proof that whatever
is committed in this new commitment to a
ledger was obtained legitimately from
whatever was committed here right that's
the that's the idea so you don't want to
like see what exists and verify why
these things are true but you won't have
this concise view and the proofs
guarantee you that these concise views
are legitimate so basically when so you
have your Genesis commitment and then
you could do prove that everything
happened legitimately but that would
mean that of course you save a lot
because you only have a few group
elements per block but it would still
grow as the blockchain grows so what
what they actually propose is that you
could do some how I met the proof and
say if this is the current blockchain
and I don't prove all these intermediate
steps but I give you a proof that these
steps exist and that's what recursive
application of snacks allow you to do
and moreover if you now
add a new block then from this old proof
you can derive a new proof that there
that authenticates this new this is mean
apparently it runs on a test net but
that can be pipelined across multiple
books with each block and we are making
progress on the main chain of proofs but
you're also merging in parallel proofs
along the tree so it's actually not so
bad but yeah is again a lot of details
that I I didn't mention this is
basically the rough rough idea of what
you can do by having recursive
zero knowledge - yeah I mean for all
these snacks that exists zero knowledge
is basically for free intuitively why
because if your proof is so succinct it
can't contain much information about
your witnesses right but it turns out
that what you do is you add a little bit
of randomness and you get your knowledge
of your fish it's really the
succinctness part that's the hard thing
to get okay in the last few minutes let
me mention again things that I've
explained in simplified form how Bitcoin
actually works so it's not that you can
only do transactions you can actually do
more complicated things because if you
make if you make a Bitcoin transaction
and it's not that you just put a public
key there and say that whoever has a
signature can spend this output but what
you do is you write the script and say
whoever finds whoever gives value so
that the script executes can spend this
output so for example if you send a
Bitcoin to an address I remember an
address is the hash of a public key then
to satisfy this you write the script so
that you can satisfy it if you give a
public key so that the hash is the
address and the signature so that it has
a public key but other things are
possible and let me just mention three
of them so for example what you can do
is you can create outputs so that you
need which are associated to several
addresses or several public keys so all
of them or some subset of them has to
sign so you could imagine a company
having all their wealth in a Bitcoin
transaction and then some qualified
majority of the board has to sign in
order to move this money you could do
that
another type of script opcode is that
that allows you to create transactions
that you can only
spend after a certain amount of time has
passed and I guess the simplest kind of
transaction is you can put a hash image
there and say whoever has a pre-image
can spend it money to a hash preimage so
the first one Multi signatures allows
you to do escrow transactions so you
could put some the public key of someone
you trust in there and in case of
dispute that person can can side with
whatever participant and then execute
the payment pay to hatch pre-pre image
allows you to do very cute protocol
which is called your knowledge
contingent payments which I'd love to
present but I don't have the time but
the idea is basically that you solve the
problem of fair exchange by using a
blockchain
so as an example suppose that I have a
pseudo coup that I really want to solve
but I don't manage to do it so I post on
the internet say whoever gives me a
solution to this pseudo coil pay them
one Bitcoin the problem now is that
these people want the money before they
sent me the solution and I want to see
the solution before I give out the money
so how can we attack whoever goes first
can lose but using this one nice
operation and some zero knowledge proof
in the background you can actually solve
this over Bitcoin so that it's
guaranteed that either I get the
solution and the person gets the money
or no one gets anything and finally you
can also by using multi signatures in
this lock time you can implement micro
payments and this allows you to this is
basically what this lightning Network
allows you to do so I'll not go through
it but the idea is that if for example I
want to offer someone to Internet access
and I charge them one cent for a minute
then I cannot do this by a Bitcoin
because a transactions are too slow and
B I will probably may pay more in fees
than that 1 cent that I get so the idea
is that you can take make payments
offline by what they call establishing a
payment channel and only when you open
and close the channel will something
actually end up in the blockchain but
still all the security guarantees that
you get in this channel that no one can
steal your money
that's bootstrapped from the blockchain
almost concludes the talk basically
these types of very special kinds of
smart contracts which means that you can
have conditions encoded on the
blockchain that are executed
automatically if certain things happen
so you can use block chains to to solve
the problem of domain registration you
can use them for gambling voting all
kinds of applications but the question
is can you have one blockchain with
which you can do anything you want and
that's basically the promise of
aetherium a universal blockchain how do
they how does this work
so in aetherium you have a built-in
program language programming language
and as opposed to Bitcoin which is very
simple it is actually turing-complete so
you can in principle write any code any
conditions that you want you have user
accounts and you have this idea of
contracts that you can upload to the
blockchain
anyone can make a contract you can send
money to contracts these contracts can
then send money elsewhere access other
contracts they have their own storage
where they so they have memory in the
blockchain yeah code can send money
write read and write storage call other
contracts and the nodes now in Bitcoin
these nodes they checked whether the
signatures were valid now they have to
actually do whatever the smart contracts
tell them the code to execute so it
seems that you get a problem here
because one of the reason why the
Bitcoin scripting language is so simple
is because you want to avoid problems
with like go back to these people namely
that you don't know how long it will
take to run the code so in Bitcoin
script you you know that you will
execute very quickly if you have a
turing-complete
programming language then you run into
turing related problems like the halting
problem so what if you put a smart
contract on that then the
- we'll just run into infinite loop that
would be bad and there is the the way
this is soft is that you just pay them
like this is any time you want the - to
do something you pay them for every
computation step that your smart
contracts makes the - work you give them
a small amount of and this is the my
last slide so what are the I guess this
links to the third workshop
decentralizing society what are the big
promises of of blockchains and smart
contracts is that you can get of get rid
of intermediaries you don't need banks
anymore you don't need courts of law if
smart contracts work the way imagine
them and you could have services that
now work in a centralized way in a
decentralized way so you could have an
air B&B where there's no company
charging money but just uses
[Applause]